okay welcome everyone to the program
we're going to start and today's session
is a part of our program called the
hands-on biomedical data science it's a
part of our series called onyx logic in
the series we talk about different types
of data and we talk about different
types of analyses as well as challenges
so this particular program the data
science program is focused on preparing
the data for analysis using
visualization using processing tools and
then using practical approaches to get
insights from that data and we'll talk a
lot about machine learning and data
normalization preparation of
visualization and other things so this
is a full course that combines
user-friendly processing and machine
learning methods designed for
high-throughput biomedical data with
practical skills in art in excel on the
T biota platform to visualize and gain
director insights and make your research
reproducible data-driven and more
impactful the program is focused on
biomedical data and we look at medical
data in the context of specific types of
data and specific types of questions and
so when we will talk through this
session today will be focused on
next-generation sequencing and our mix
technologies so we'll talk about a
variety of different use cases for this
type of technology and we'll talk about
different tools that you can use to
process and analyze this kind of data
and so today's session is again a free
session for anybody that is learning
about the Onix logic program learning
about the specific data science program
if you're still not registered we
encourage you to ask any questions that
you have about the program the duration
of the program the types of activities
that we have and you can place your
questions in the chat box and we'll be
happy to answer those so I hope that
everybody that wanted to join has joined
and let's talk about
the program a little bit so the program
is split up into five different parts
four of these parts are introductory in
in the sense that they are designed for
training and then the fifth part is
actually focused on projects so this
session is going to be the conclusion of
our introductory session section and the
introductory section is really designed
to introduce everybody to
high-throughput data experiments
challenges and opportunities associated
with high-throughput molecular data and
it will introduce different types of
omics technologies including genomics
transcriptomics and other type of data
types for example metagenomics and we'll
talk about different types of studies
studies related to precision medicine
molecular data analysis for mechanistic
understanding and topics like drug
discovery and discovery of drug efficacy
then the second portion of the program
we will be talking about exploratory
data analysis the need for statistical
understanding of our data properties and
characteristics and the way to prepare
data for analysis so a lot of steps are
needed to introduce first of all convert
the data from unstructured to structured
and then once that processing step is
done you also have to play around with
data to prepare it for the type of
analysis that you will be doing because
these different analysis techniques have
assumptions about the data data
distribution and other properties that
we'll learn how to identify by looking
at our data from the standpoint of
visualization and statistical analysis
so we'll talk about probability
correlation Association and we'll talk
about some common data visualization
techniques that are typically used for
exploratory data analysis and we'll use
two examples using Excel and using R and
we'll start talking about how you can
and you know I don't think there's
anything wrong with doing things in
Excel there's nothing wrong with doing
things in are a lot of people would
probably do it in both some things are
easier to do in Excel some things are
easier easier to do an are it eventually
as you specialize you kind of pick the
type of environment that is most
relevant to what you are doing so after
that we're going to talk about data
mining for data mining we'll talk about
machine learning techniques that help us
reduce the dimensionality of our data so
things like principal component analysis
and some others and then we'll talk
about what are the features what are the
objects how do we actually find insights
using some of these data mining
techniques and we'll talk about
clustering methods as well and in the
context of clustering and principal
component analysis we will also talk
about data preparation that can help us
make the most insights when we look at
the results then we'll talk about
classification and classification is a
number of machine learning methods that
are used for discriminant analysis
decision trees using varieties of
decision trees like random forests and
support vector machines so we'll really
talk about a number of different methods
there after these first five sections of
the program we believe that any one of
you is going to be ready to do their own
analysis now this is not a requirement
this is something that we think is going
to be helpful to you so we will help
prepare the project idea so that your
project idea is clear and very defined
and focused and then we will help you
apply your idea in the project design to
the actual data set of your choice so
we'll talk about how to find the data
how to prepare the data how to process
and analyze the data and then finally
how might you interpret that data during
that time will be available to help on a
one-on-one basis that you will be able
to connect with some of our team and
discuss but also will kind of walk you
through a structured process of
submitting that kind of information so
what is omics data let's talk about
the history of genomic data tarnished in
how we got to where we are today so as
we all remember in the 1950s the DNA
double helix structure was discovered
and as a result of that discovery we
understood that so the way that this
data is recorded in the DNA has to do
with a sequence and that sequence of DNA
that nucleotides in the DNA is truly
what we call today genomic data so later
on is this discovery became more
practical what we applied it to is the
assembly of a full genome how do we put
together a full sequence and in this
case we used it on the human genome
again somebody turning on the microphone
so I'm going to okay and anyone that's
joining just please mute yourself as you
are joining again if you have your video
on you can go ahead and turn that off
and if you have any questions please
feel free to to ask them in chat okay so
assembly of the human genome project
just to give you a perspective where we
are today with that as a result of that
project the human genome project
next-generation sequencing was started
to become more more affordable and so
Illumina picked up that idea of shotgun
sequencing and really made a very
popular nowadays application
next-generation sequencing making me a
cheaper and more effective and more
precise so as a result we now have in
2015 by 2015 there was already 1,000 of
genomes of human genomes and that was
the 1000 genome
and in 2018 we're actually talking about
thousands and thousands of genomes for
example there's a 100 thousand genome
project by genomics England and in that
the Broad Institute and recently you
might have heard that the UK biobank is
a new project that is the most ambitious
yet that will actually assemble five
hundred thousand genomes so there is an
exponential growth of this data look
what is this data really look like so
the data really comes in a sequencing
machine that looks something like this
this is the high seek 2500 and the high
C 2500 produces fast queue format of
data so the fast you form a lot of data
when we say it's unstructured it looks
like this so it essentially has reached
these short reads can be anywhere
between 30 and 300 base pairs long and
for each one of these letters that you
see here you have a quality score as
well and that's why it's called fast QQ
stands for quality we also collect
information that was assembled from
these short reads in files that are
FASTA format so for example the human
genome would be in the FASTA format so
this is the same type of a format where
you can see individual letters of the
code but they don't contain the quality
they actually are assembled and longer
read so here you can see reads and
sometimes you can also see whole
chromosomes assembled in a file that
looks like this
so what is you know what are some uses
for the FASTA files the FASTA files are
actually files that a lot of times are
used for full genome so here you can see
a couple of full genomes so this is the
genome of spot-up terror forged era
where you can see that this is the
genome shotgun sequence so it's an
assembly of the full genome and it looks
something like this this is a virus
right here and the right the complete
genome of this rabies virus looks
something like this so it's just a
continuous sequence of letters
what is shotgun sequencing shotgun
sequencing so
as you saw over here these are
individual reads so let's try and
understand how these reads actually are
prepared so these reads are first the
DNA the genomic DNA is shattered as it
sheared into these pieces and these
pieces about 200-300 base pair fragments
you can see that then adapters are
attached to the beginning and end of
each read and this is an example of a
paired end read sequencing and then in a
flow cell that data is amplified using
PCR amplification then the sequencer
what it does is it reads out in each
flow cell it looks at the color and the
color is associated with a letter that's
why you also have the quality control
because the letters are not always so
clear that you can understand that that
is let's say T G C or a and so as a
result we have this kind of a sequence
as you saw there's a label so for
example you can see here that this is
the label of the read this is an
individual position of that read and
this is the quality so the cue score is
25 how is next generation sequencing
applied in the context of this
biological process that happens at the
subcellular level and I'm sorry I see
that we have something on the screen so
let me just see how I can maybe remove
that annotation okay so as you all know
the cell inside the cell there's the
nucleus and the nucleus contains the DNA
but that DNA is expressed in proteins
which are the functional molecules in
the cell so here in this representation
let's just break down the type of onyx
data that we have for each level of
information that we can
came from the south so first of all the
external phenotype the external
observation about what the cell looks
like its shape etc is called the
phenotype and we call that phenomics
right so it's not really autumn ecstatic
census that it's next generation
sequencing data but we can also generate
a lot of images a lot of characteristics
so this could be one type of data then
we have the genomic data the genomic
data is really what is recorded in the
DNA and so here you can see an analysis
of genomic data and essentially it tells
you what is in the DNA of this specific
sample and what is in the reference
genome so what is in the sample compared
to the reference genome and we'll talk
about some of the other things that we
can do with this kind of data then
growing area is called epigenetic
analysis or epigenomics epigenomics is
really the analysis of DNA methylation
and histone modification that we can
look at from bisulfite sequencing or
chip sequences chromatin
immunoprecipitation and then we have
transcriptomics transcriptomics is the
analysis of expression of mRNA and we
can also talk about other types of rnase
micro rna's and other types of small RNA
so there's really a number of different
things that we can study using just
next-generation sequencing for example
in each one of these cases you will have
a different approach to process that
data in order to structure the data for
example an RNA sequencing it's really
the alignment of the reads to the genome
and the quantification of the aligned
reads to beans or isoforms in DNA
microarray for example we can look at
how we spot the changes in individual
positions and that will be called
variant calling that could be done with
Illumina next-generation sequencing or
microarray data and then chip seek is
chromatin immunoprecipitation as we
spoke and chromatin immunoprecipitation
allows us to understand where the
histones are bound to the DNA so
identify those binding sites RNA editing
also explore how RNA is edited in the
process of alternative splicing and when
it becomes a mature micro RNA so in the
context of data analysis on the platform
that we already started introducing last
time these are some of the sections so
you can see that we have a whole section
on next-generation sequencing data and
we'll try a couple of these sections to
understand how the data gets converted
from this raw fast queue format of short
reads eventually to a structured table
that we can actually use in downstream
analysis starting from exploratory data
analysis which is going to be the next
topic that we will cover so here you can
see only seek transcriptomics genomics
and epigenetics you can see the whole
exome sequencing whole genome sequencing
bisulfite sequencing that let me talked
about copy number of a segmentation or
copy number variation where we can look
at number of genes that are recorded
multiple times in the genome and also
metagenomics so how can we analyze data
from microbial communities the
microbiome so all of these are important
things to understand but they all share
common principles and so what we want to
look at today are some of those
principles that are applied in two types
of data transcriptomics and genomics so
one deals with next-generation
sequencing of gene expression and
another one deals with next-generation
sequencing of genomic sequence the
genomic variants so let's first talk
about next generation sequencing
transcriptomics we have the DNA and the
DNA only about 1% of that DNA is
dedicated to coding genes in other words
sections of the DNA that record a
sequence of a gene and those genes are
not going to be expressed exactly the
same way that they are mrna that they
are transcripts so transcript will
be a little bit different from the
actual gene so the gene gets expressed
some genes don't get expressed some get
expressed more some get expressed less
and this mRNA is what we have in our
sample and the sample the sample is
shattered so you can see that it's
broken down into these short reads
adapters are attached to the beginning
of the end of each one of those reads
then those reads are amplified using PCR
amplification and then finally they are
read so the understanding of how the
data is prepared is critical for our
ability to appropriately process it and
prepare it for analysis so what we want
to look at now is we want to take a look
at how we can take this understanding
and convert it into a data analysis
pipeline now another aspect of gene
expression is that as we said genes the
way they're recorded in the DNA and the
way that they are actually expressed are
not exactly the same way so there's a
process of alternative splicing we won't
go into detail but let's talk about it
from that analysis standpoint so one of
the critical steps is alignment
alignment of these short reads as you
can see right here these are the
different reads that we have in our data
and this is the reference so the
reference has some kind of a sequence of
letters some gaps and we have a number
of reads and the reads as you can see
that it will all start from the same
location so the process of alignment is
actually looking at how do those reads
align to the reference genome and then
using this alignment to understand what
kind of exons do we have that combine in
an actual that are combined into an
actual Taizo form so let's talk about
how this works in real life we started
doing this last time let's do this a
little bit again by going to the
platform so a thank you protein for
putting in that link
the the platform that I am referring to
is the server dot T - bio info so all of
you that have registered for the program
should have already received your
account information if you have not
received your account information you
just registered please ask us about this
we will be sending you those details
today as soon as the session is over so
the again the server will look something
like this when you are there and if you
want to see that you are logged in you
will see your details right here in this
corner
and what we want to do today is just
briefly go through some of the example
pipelines for rna-seq and for whole
exome seek data to do this we actually
have a full course that you can take on
transcriptomics and on genomics that you
can learn about how this works
but in the meantime you can just learn
about looking at some of these examples
that we have at demo pipeline we will
try to explain as much as possible how
these work as we do these pipelines so
right here under transcriptomics we have
this RNA seek chip parallel analysis of
next-generation sequencing and
microarray data and we are going to take
this first demo pipeline the demo
pipeline uses the cell line data that we
started discussing last time the context
of the data is that we are using data
from a publication publicly available
data these are patient derived cell
lines and we are going to analyze that
data for gene expression that can help
us identify cell types of cancer so
let's take a look at how do we prepare
several samples into a table of
expression by pressing on start you can
read a little bit about some of the
critical steps that are involved in this
process so as you can see we are going
to start by first pre-processing so
pre-processing will help us remove those
adapters that were attached and removed
the
see our duplicates then we are going to
map the data that we have to a reference
genome and then we're going to quantify
the levels of expression so the pipeline
will look something like this you can
see that this whole section is dealing
with pre-processing this section deals
with mapping on transcripts and this
deals with quantification of expression
levels so this is just one example of a
pipeline that we can build now you can
see that the buttons have become darker
that I can select and what I'll do is
I'll first use the pre-processing
section to use trim Ematic that will
find the actual read sequences and
remove the adapters and any technical
sequences that might be contaminating
some of the data that we have then we
will look for this step of amplification
so VCR amplification does not always
amplify every section that in a similar
way so what we want to do is we want to
remove this technical amplification so
that we are left with data that is
directly related to the biological
problem the conditions that we are
trying to study now then we have two
different options you can see that
there's an option for hiset which is
going to be a combined strategy on
mapping on the genome detection of exons
and then mapping on junctions so there's
really a combined strategy or we can
directly map on transcripts what's the
difference well the difference is as I
mentioned the genes that are known the
transcripts that are known and are
recorded in an annotation file called
GTF file they are not really
representative of all the biological
variability that exists in real life and
so if we want something very detailed to
understand the alternative splicing
events that we have per sample and
really understand the eyes of forms that
are expressed in each sample we wouldn't
want to use this combined strategy if we
want to just understand known isoforms
or known genes
they expressed we will use this
annotation file and computationally this
is a more effective way of doing it but
you lose some resolution
so let's first try this one now here you
can see that we're going to be aligning
these reeds to the reference genome and
we will use an algorithm called bowtie 2
and bowtie 2 is a fast alignment
algorithm that is based on the seed or
Kaymer approach so this approach is
actually somewhat similar to what is
used in the burro wheelers algorithm
that's similar to what is used and when
you search for something in Google for
example it's just an effective algorithm
to align a sequence to another sequence
so once we align our sequences those
short reads to the genome and we
understand or to the transcriptome sorry
and we understand that they have covered
they have certain coverage and then they
have a certain amplification in a region
one of the other challenges is to then
quantify taking into account the number
of reads that we have in total and
really prepare do but a real number so
here you can see what that table will
eventually look like you can see that we
will have the gene ID the gene name
across multiple samples all the samples
that we uploaded and for each sample we
will have a number and that number
represents the level of expression so
let's click on OK now we have prepared
our data pre-processing we then map the
data on transcripts quantified it using
expectation-maximization technique which
is also a machine learning method
actually and then we will complete by
pressing on it now if you are interested
in learning more about some of these
transcriptomic data analysis we
encourage you to go to this link
transcriptomics we have a whole section
here on transcriptomics so you are
welcome to take those courses those
courses are free and they walk you
through all of the steps that I just
described right now
but also take it further to talk about
differential gene expression and talk
about some of the machine learning that
we can apply to this kind of data as
well as all the way to single-cell RNA
seek which is a separate section on the
platform now once this pipeline
completes again what is the concept of
the pipeline the pipeline is taking the
data loading in to each one of these
algorithms completing the algorithm it's
a sequential process where we take the
data that goes into the input that
process that a script or algorithm
produces a result and then we pass it on
to the next job so that's really what
the pipeline is and here what you can
see is a logical representation of this
pipeline let's take a look at the result
so we have here a data set called cell
lines expression data so we can download
this data just by clicking right here
and once the data is downloaded we can
take a look at what's inside so we can
open this data for example a quickest
way to open it and let's just open it in
Excel so in Excel we'll be able to see
what the structured version of this data
looks like we saw what the fast q files
look like and obviously this is
something that very difficult to deal
with and here we can see how we can
convert those fast u files into a
structured format this is called the
structured format because it essentially
organizes the data by some feature this
right here is the ID of a gene and this
right here is the ID of the sample of
the stela so in here we have these
numbers and these numbers represent the
level of expression of this particular
gene in this particular sample okay so
this was one of the one of the examples
for a an RNA seek pipeline let's just
quickly try and create the other more
complex version of this pipeline so
again you can see here that we can start
with preparing the data by
pre-processing the data then we can use
high Sat to
which is an algorithm that will look for
these variety of ways that the exons
could be mapped on the actual genome and
it prepares isoforms and so we need to
now construct these isoforms by looking
at the variability because some samples
will have exons present other will not
have and so we need to have a full list
of all of those possible Isak forms and
then we will use that understanding of
the isoforms to actually generate a new
GTF file so the new GTF file will tell
us what we are actually mapping on to
right because at the end we will map the
reads that we have onto these
transcripts and once we map those onto
the transcripts again we need to
quantify the data that we have and once
we quantify the data that we have one
obvious step that we can do is compare
conditions and this is something that
we'll talk a lot more about in future
lectures where we will use de seek de
seek we'll look at differential gene
expression so for example this is
condition number one this is condition
number two where are those statistically
significant genes that are
differentially expressed between two
conditions so we'll talk a lot more
about some of these concepts in our
lectures but also encourage all of you
that this is covered in transcriptomics
- you can learn about the p-values and
the false discovery rate and and all
kinds of other concepts that are
relevant to this topic now you can see
that now we have a bunch more different
outputs here and the reason is because
we are just going through this kind of
step by step to understand the
complexity right so what are some of the
files that we have we have the mapping
statistics so how many are the reads
were mapped to the genome how many were
not we have the expression of eyes
deforms we have the expression of genes
and you will notice here fpkm
and other kind of abbreviations and
we'll talk a lot more about what these
abbreviations mean and how do we
actually use a variety of normalization
techniques to prepare data for analysis
so that was a little bit on the
transcriptomic data analysis and the
transcriptomic data analysis is really
something that we see as a preliminary
step before we can start analyzing and
understanding our data so at this point
I'm going to just take a moment here and
ask anyone if anyone of you has any
questions about this process please feel
free to put those questions into the
chat and we'll be happy to answer those
now we saw how pre-processing of data
mapping of that data on the reference
genome and then some kind of analysis in
that case it was quantification is used
to analyze RNA sequencing data now let's
talk about genomics data genomic data is
different and we can use a variety of
methods to analyze that data and so
we'll look briefly at how we can look at
individual single nucleotide
polymorphisms or snips or snv's so we
can look at single nucleotide variation
or we can look at copy number variation
copy number variation is variation of
the number of times that a gene is
recorded in the DNA how do we use this
data so how do we use this we one of the
ways that it could be done is by looking
at genome-wide Association so for
example how do we now associate this
variation with the phenotype that we
have
about the sample just briefly going
through some of the sections that we
have here we have pre-processing mapping
an alignment that you're already
familiar with and then some new sections
including variant caller differential
variant color for example for the
detection of somatic mutations
annotation of the data which positions
are where and why is that important for
example using the 1000 genomes project
using the database of clinically
relevant snips etc and then we have some
post-processing sections here as well
here are a couple of different pipelines
that could be created to look at the
data from different standpoints let's
try and create those together so that we
understand what type of information we
can get out of them so I can see here
that somebody has raised their hands
maybe at this point it would be best if
you could just type your question into
the chat and would be happy to address
that or we can wait until we have the
Q&A session at the end so right here you
can see mutation variant parallel
analysis for mutation data by the way if
you are interested to understand how all
of these sections work you can just
quickly hover over and that will tell
you a little bit of a background of what
were you looking at so parallel analysis
of mutation variant if you click here
again we are going to use the same
project the same cell lines that these
are breast cancer cell lines we're
trying to understand subtypes of
different breast cancers and one of the
ways to look at the subtypes is to try
and look at the genomic variation so
let's quickly create one of our first
pipelines now it's important to
understand that the individual positions
that are changing in the DNA actually
have an impact on the way that the
protein ultimately will be produced but
the protein is produced from mRNA so the
process of going from DNA to mRNA to
protein is clarified by this ability to
look at first of all how the Tri codons
or sorry the descry nucleotide
codons are we recorded and then how
those codons produce amino acids so
quickly a question here how to upload
default fast queue files so this is a
demo version and then when we talk about
actual processing of the data you will
use the non demo accounts and there are
a few steps to configure before you
actually upload but then we will use we
are happy you know maybe to get on a
call to explain how to use that so but
to run the default pipeline there's no
need to upload anything this is just a
demo ok so one of the things that we can
do is we can align the data to the
reference genome and then we can
visualize that right so to visualize the
data what we can do is use J browse a
method that will show us the actual the
actual reads align to the reference
genome so once we click on end you can
also see here that we have a collection
of lectures on genomics including
introduction to genomics and genomics 1
and right now we are working on genomics
2 that will be available soon so let's
take a look at the results of
visualization so this is the
visualization of a couple of samples so
you can see here that I have two samples
srr 9 2 5 7 6 5 and sr9 2 5 7 6 6 so
this is just two files and this is the
alignment of those reads to the
reference genome so you can see that I
have a sequence of the genome and then I
have accumulation of reads so this is
called the abundance and then here I can
actually see the nucleotides and I can
see individual positions where I have a
change right and you can see that this
change is identified by this little mark
on this level now if i zoom out I'm just
going to quickly zoom out here you can
see that actually only portions of the
genome
have some coverage so the coverage of
the genome is positioned right here I
can see the annotation that GTF file
that we started talking about and the
GTF file records the positions of exons
and genes on the genome so now I have
this annotated annotation or the
annotation move with the positions of
these exons and genes you can see that
this is a gene called p53 and p53 of
course is a gene that is important for
somatic mutations occurring in apoptosis
and an important gene in cancer so you
can see a number of things from just
visualizing this data first of all we
know that this is whole exome sequencing
right because as the reads are only
positioned in the regions annotated by
gene so this is only gene so that's what
whole exome sequencing means the second
thing is that we can quickly browse
through and look at a variety of
positions and even search here for
various genes that we know for example
the breast cancer gene the brachot gene
can be found right here and we can take
a look at this gene it will tell you
that it's in chromosome 17 if you go
back to p53 you will see that it will
take you to that position of the p53
gene which is actually on chromosome 1
so you can see how this is a huge amount
of data very difficult to scroll through
and just look at things from that
perspective but very informative if you
are know if you know what you are
looking for so let's try another type of
an analysis another type of an analysis
is when we want to identify somatic
mutations and somatic mutations means
that one we have one type of say one
sample from let's say the tumor and
another sample from let's say the blood
sample the normal sample of the same
person and we can separate the germline
mutations from the somatic mutation so
how is that
we can again pre-process our data align
the data to the reference genome and
then do what's called somatic mutation
calling so for example using strelka
strelka is a method for somatic SMV
single nucleotide variation and small
endo detection from sequencing data of
matched tumor normal samples so you can
see the representation of what this
algorithm does and what it ultimately
produce and produces a variant call file
on VCF file we can also use another
method method called somatic sniper and
it's important to understand that for a
lot of these steps you can use multiple
alternatives and maybe these
alternatives will produce different
types of results but in this case you
can get a zip file that will include
both a text file that is a table of each
individual positions and a variant call
file in the variant call file the VCF
file can actually be further explored by
looking at just somatic mutation so
again just a quick review here we looked
at coverage we looked at different
positions on the GTF file in the genome
and we looked at how do we understand
what type of information we're looking
at and where are those important
positions for us to look at we also saw
how it's not a straightforward process
for us to just browse through all of
them information that we have that is
really where the need for data analysis
comes in and one of the things that we
talked about is the p53 gene the gene
and chromosomes have chromosome 11 I
think is supposed to be where our
chromosome 17 yes sorry that we can now
interpret right being an important gene
in the tumor or in the cancer when we
are trying to analyze for cancer
mutations so this is an example of how
we can visualize
the VCF file and here you can see the
p53 gene this is the human genome so you
can see it's in the human genome has to
be used as the reference and then we
have the chromosome 17 the positions of
this gene and those individual mutations
and somatic mutations in this gene now
how does this all apply to this problem
of precision treatment of breast cancer
to talk about this and to take any
questions that you might have I am going
to pass on the host to protein and
protein Chakravarthy is has a PhD in
bioinformatics and has been a trainer
with behind biotech with with us for a
number of months and he'll be able to
walk you through some of the project
design ideas and answer any of your
questions about this about what I've
shown so before so I'm going to transfer
this over to brew team for Tina clinking
yeah can you hear me all of you guys yes
we can hear you okay should I share my
screen or should you continue sharing oh
yeah I am going to I stop sharing my
screen and I think you know I should -
perfect so I think all of you are able
to see my screen now
so yes any questions you have which I
would like to answer whatever earlier
covered is thank you for that it was a
pretty good you know a sufficient
understanding from the previous lecture
that what we are going to cover on and
these are some of the applications that
you can find in front of you like
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer because breast cancer of several
subtypes like chlorine low or normal or
basal or you know there are some other
classes as well and maybe these things
these these this map out here right now
make sense little bit up to you about
the coverage or the mutations that are
being shown out here and also the
phenomics think the molecular profiling
of the breast cancer and also the
coverage because the coverage is very
important when it comes to
next-generation sequencing because a
good coverage definitely gives you all
those details about those data so this
is one of the article very significant
article which is there and trying to in
front of you so where we try to
understand the cancer profiles by using
the machine learning principles which
are going to cover in this course entire
length of this course for the next three
months and you know and then I would
like to go to you know this other some
of the projects which so reproducibility
is the need of the hour so you need
before jumping into some project or
trying to do some solving some problems
you need to have the biological
questions pretty well-defined in your
mind and would definitely like to help
you guys to you know doing this project
which is a very important part of this
course so two months of intensive
learning which will be guided by experts
like Ilya Darko and Mohit and thereafter
you have to embark yourself in doing the
project whatever you have learned to
analyze the data so these are some of
the archives from where you can get your
data from one of them is sequence read
archive which is a part of NCBI in
Serbia is a data warehouse where
these are the data has been submitted by
various from various experiments and on
the left you can find you know
transcriptome analysis of spa doctor of
roogie pada these is one of the projects
which are available in our educational
platform those of you are part of this
course you'll be able to access it those
of you are not yet a part of this course
you will also be able to access it but
again you know you need the server
credentials which is a part of this
course anybody wants to join I think I
have already pasted the link in the chat
you can get back to us via our email or
you can get back to us you know directly
pay into the course and then join it and
carry on with the follow for the next
three months
okay anyone any questions you have I
would take up take off want to take a
pause here and I'm hearing many of you
who are already a part of this course
you can unmute yourself and ask me so we
have a question in the chair let's see
yeah server login pipe and I recovering
Sarcos - what do you exactly mean by
Sarcos if you may tell us Anika so I
think Sunita it would be best it would
be best
wear so if you have logon on to the
server can you really tell us what is
sarcos
yeah Thank You Darko I think that kind
of answers your question okay if I if I
may move on so so the omics logic
training program which is going to cover
for the next three months is going to be
very intensive in trying to understand
our data processing and analysis and
visualizations in any sort of academic
or research or industrial exercise or
industrial projects what you need to do
the most of the data that Aliya already
told you about is unstructured you know
when it comes to if you really look at
the NGS data they are kind of being
produced by different type of machines
and all those machines produce different
type of you know formats so what the
major problem in the Big Data domain
right now is to structure the data it
when it comes to any other domain that
biomedical domain if you go to the you
know electronics data or electrical data
or any sort of data out there the
important part is structuring the data
from the unstructured form even in
biomedical data domain big data domain
besides NGS there are electronic health
records or electronic medical records
there are several points that there are
images there are pixels you know the
electronic medical records contain the
name of the person the gender of the
person the age and the height and the
BMI and all those typical important
things that you have to kind of fill up
a form in your pathological labs or in
the clinic so connecting all those EMR
data sets which are basically clinical
data sets these are piling up in a huge
way and thereby producing the level of
the actual deluge of the big data so
this is highly unstructured so whatever
processes that has been shown to you by
earlier on the pre-processing part
thereby we try to structure it properly
because if you don't structure it
properly it would
the statistical principles that are
being used that we are intending to use
at the part of the machine learning at
the same time it won't be applicable
because genomics data coming directly
from the platform from any sort of
India's experiment does not follow
normal distribution standard normal
distribution is an essential starting
point for analyzing data end up with the
statistical tools so before you actually
try to find all those patterns the
mutational variant or the differential
gene expression or the differential
variants all those somatic mutations and
the online mutation it is essential that
you need to structure the data first
that's an advantage and that's also is a
big disadvantage as well so but I know
you know there are processes to
circumvent that is advantageous out here
to structure it properly because if you
have all those raw short reads which are
kind of have to be mapped onto the
genome have we have to kind of get the
whole sequence out of it then then only
we'll be able to find out those
significant genes and also those
important biomarkers which can be used
in precision medicine or in any other
domains that are being used right now
different concepts are coming up you
know because epi transcriptome epigenome
is also is something which already
earlier covered though histone
modification the methylation of it so
single celled transcriptomics is it also
you know he producing huge amount of
data but again this is unstructured and
we teach you out here in this course to
do the structuring of the data the
processing of the data and definitely
Big Data has a very important factor
which is visualization because until and
unless you visualize something in front
of you you know
you know you know in a big good way you
would definitely be able to understand
that
where does your data fall what class are
you develop it uh volunteer so you have
a hypothesis you have a by the
biological hypothesis to prove and these
hypothesis whether it really makes sense
or not if you visualize the data that
would be the best thing to do at your
end and you know that the methods that
we teach you we would try to you know
guide you through during the entire
length of this course has clinical
perspective have
perspective and obviously pharmaceutical
projects you know there are significant
pharmaceutical projects or significant
pharmaceutical problems which are
occurring at the end of the day which
are coming up you know they are being
addressed there has to be addressed from
the big data perspective so we teach you
the methods and we help you to apply
those methods in those three
perspectives I think most of the
participants out here belong to that
domain and if you don't are not
belonging to the domain if you are a you
know trying to understand the data
science principles of course the
principles that we teach out here is
applicable for any sort of data so be
biomedical data or any other data only
the structuring principles will be
different you know that data types will
be different so the basic principles
remaining the same whether it's
biomedical data or the question will
differ so that has to be you know would
be a good exercise for you to go through
this course and have a hang of things
so in throughout the entire length of
our course we give a lot of pointers
we'll give you a lot of pointers to
learn about it we do not really you know
its its hourly lecture we do not it is
not intended to you know just mug the
things up so that's why we have built
that educational platform which actually
supplements the server platform so any
other one any other those of you have
registered for the pols I've already had
the access to the server so run at all
of them of pipelines try to understand
the input files that's why the demo pie
trends are therefore so and that would
really help you to figure out a way to
you know how you know you can really
match or cope with the type of the
things that we're going to cover in the
entire three months of course and you
know these we can design and prepare and
plan in analysis and make it impactful
because that is the whole idea of it
this is a hands-on learning course it's
not about theories only so you have to
know the essential theories which will
be covered in detail and you will also
be guided through the projects you know
the project which can come as a novel
project from your part or you can do
some of the projects that we have in the
in our in our educational platform you
can go to them try to understand the
produce ability of the research that's
the important part of it so once a
research can be reproduced the methods
if you have a very clear idea about the
methods that you are you know you're
going to follow that would really
translate in the process of your own
research so so that's that's the whole
idea of this omics logic training
program and as a result of this omics
Rajic training program you will have a
very detailed portfolio yes anybody had
any question Rana
could you do to yourself please Rana can
you mute your sir please thank you very
much so you know as a part of this omics
logic training program the whole idea of
is to help you to build your portfolio I
have heard I come across many many
participants here in this course who are
interested to learn data science as a
whole and definitely you know until
unless you actually dig your hand into
the soil you won't be able to understand
how deep is the soil or how how dirty is
the soil so that's what it is all about
in our program that you can build your
portfolio and can say up front that ok I
know this and I know the algorithms and
I know the basic procedures of machine
learning principles and because you have
you know that's the whole idea of it to
build to do the project and you know the
biomedical research so also for people
who are for doing academic research and
as well as for those people who are
doing Industrial Research this type of
courses would definitely help you
because we have worked in industries for
a long time we have seen that you know
in real life examples that are being
thrown at you from your clients it's all
about it the research you know you have
to understand the data you have to
structure the data try to understand the
biological question your client is
trying to solve and help those clients
to solve those patients so courses like
this would definitely help you to
critically understand the scientific
concepts behind it in the biomedical
domain
and of course as a part of your course
we would also be helping you out to
understand to read research publications
because that's the only way you can
really advance your knowledge to a
different level so because most of the
elementary research which goes on in the
Academy a-- are have some translational
applications in that industry as well so
biomedical research is it will be
clarified to you and the research
publications would be shared with you
and also if you come across any research
publications which is of the ol own
interest for your own work we can help
you to decipher that to demystify that
as a part of your doing your project and
definitely the certification is very
important in any sort of course so the
the course entire length of the course
is for three months at the end of that
you would get a certificate which is in
turn internationally accredited it comes
from buying biotech it comes from
trouble bioinformatics research centre
from where we are a technological
spin-off and you know at the same time
as a part of this course the the
educational platform have a number of
modules hovering around the genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
etc so all these modules also have
significant individual certificates when
you complete the courses so you can you
know you have to know the data sources
because if you do not know a data source
you cannot really call yourself you know
a proper data scientist you know what
what what is need to be done as a data
scientist able to understand where the
data is coming from and how the data is
structured and how what what sort of you
know things that parameters need to be
said to make your unstructured data into
a structured way so that's what we are
trying to teach here as a part of the
biomedical data science course so you
can understand the basic principles of
the data and also the basic methods
which are used to structure the data so
and you know and the project at the
end of the course would help you to to
make your learning into a translational
into into a translational objective so
so this this course have a
pre-assessment and a post-assessment
and a midterm assessment would really
like to understand that what you have
really learned where where you and at
the end of the course where work where
are you
so that's very important we call our
courses extended MOOC extended massive
online course because we have a very
strong feedback system as you can
understand we have you know significant
team sitting here to help you out with
your queries and your understanding so
we are available via chat we are
available via many of the social media
platforms the number of questions I can
see this has been a dark oh thank you
very much and yeah thank you Darko
so yeah Sunita you have a question to us
okay so this much from my side I would
really like to take up any questions if
you have if you want to join the program
I have already posted the link out there
in the in the link in the chat if you
are if you are not aware of the link I
would like to host the link once again
to you and I would be really happy to
take up question so we'll be covering
again we'll be covering the data sources
and we'll be covering all those
analytical pipelines which are used to
analyze those data and come up to a
plausible interpretation in terms of
genomics in terms of transcriptomics in
terms of metagenomics as well and
epigenomics as well and we will also be
covering you know a lot of things which
comes as inherently to biomedical data
analysis which is you know data
visualization and we use our studio we
have next word with us Darko Darko is
the dark Ellie on it would be helping
you out to really understand all those
code modifications and the level of at
the level of the programming level so
you can you can you know run the
pipeline you can we have a
those are scripts are downloadable and
you can use all those downstream
analysis in the our studio and really
come up with an interval so that but
from my side I would be happy to answer
your question if you have anything you
can paste in the chat or you can unmute
yourself and ask me see many questions
in the chat Randy ok yeah so yeah thank
you very much
yeah so I think apart thank you apart
for posting the link if you want to join
the program that's the link you can see
on my screen a do dot T - bio dot info /
organizations slash comics logic - data
science slash so this is the place where
you can go you can find the curriculum
will be recover and also you would be
you know we can help you out to register
if you are not being able to pay and
register you can send email to ask at
you know at this place brought in at the
rate of Pi in dot bio or marketing at
the rate fine dot bio and yeah thank you
apart and yes Mohit protein and
marketing we have pizza with us pizza is
our community manager she will help you
out to solve your problem and help you
to join in the course though this is the
second session the next session is on
you know this is the entire length of
the course and I think I'm over I would
be happy to answer you or if you don't
have any questions I think we are
already you know at the end of our
session we put